today we're making one of my favorite
comfort dishes this is Vietnamese Ginger
braised chicken hey what's up guys my
name is David Nguyen and I am based in
Orange County California I was at home
during the pandemic and had nothing to
do I used that time to share my recipes
[Music]
I got a couple of questions asking why
my family moved back to Vietnam after
escaping to the Philippines the answer
to that is we didn't have a choice dad
went back to being a mechanic while Mom
sold rice plates as a street vendor I
remember mornings before school I would
have a plate of her gumtum I sat on a
small plastic stool at her street size
setup and watched as she sold plates
after plates of rice to her customers
ultimately my mom inspired me to cook
she's my biggest inspiration and the
reason why I'm cooking today
foreign